Each member of the Madrigal family from Disney's
"Encanto" is given a gift that reflects their
personality and can be used to help the community.
Yet not all of the Madrigals' gifts are equally
useful.
Many adults will notice this seems to be especially
true of Mirabel's, who has been given the
miraculous power to control the weather.
While this would normally be an incredible
gift, Pepa isn't like Storm from "X-Men" who
can summon rain and wind at will.
Instead, she's a bundle of emotions whose
mood is reflected in the weather she conjures.
As a result, throughout "Encanto," Pepa is
seen with clouds hovering above her head signifying
the anxiety she seems to feel almost constantly.
Pepa's gift is well suited to her stressed
out personality, given how deep her emotions
seem to run.
However, it appears Pepa hasn't managed to
harness her feelings in a way that enables
her to turn her gift to anyone's advantage.
She's honestly kind of a wreck.
And that's something most kid viewers probably
didn't notice — but the adults watching sure did.